was totally captivated by loved it
stan i thought maybe islam is the answer
it really makes me think about
becoming a muslim we'll be discussing
that and also
revisiting liam neeson's trip that he
did years ago to turkey
yeah so you have been traveling a lot
huh yeah yeah
yeah and and this movie takes place in
istanbul istanbul
and how was that we'll also touch upon
that and then
it's into your soul became the most
magnificent
wake-up call
[Laughter]
are you guys ready i thought this was
very important now we all knew
about the trip that liam neeson who's
liam neeson leonism is a very
very famous actor he's from irish
descent
and he is known for some films i believe
he was filming taken
to in turkey that was some time ago that
was years ago actually
and the word got around that he was
considering accepting
islam maybe islam is the answer really
makes me think about
becoming a muslim so let's get into this
clip let's
watch it again there's another part to
it that i never
seen until now someone sent it to me so
that's what had me want to revisit this
and go ahead and derive some benefits
from it so let's get into the clip
and this movie takes place in istanbul
and how was that it was beautiful it's a
stunning
city it used to be in the old days known
as constantinople
is the gateway between the west and the
east right
it's rich culturally historically and
there are four thousand
so he's uh talking about his trip he was
filming a movie a film in turkey
and one point from here that we can
derive from people who've been fed a lot
of this hate about muslims and
if you go to a predominantly muslim
country and you're not yet muslim and
i'm muslim that you're gonna get your
head chopped off you're gonna
all sorts of evil is gonna happen to you
do what he did do what many have done
visit a predominantly muslim country and
see how you're treated i mean
talk to people get out of your comfort
zone get out of your village get out of
your
local area your block and travel this is
another way to eradicate some of this
anti-islamism
this anti-muslim fear that many people
have connect and if you can't
leave your town or if you can't leave
your city uh
visit a mosque visit some muslims so
let's continue on
the call to prayer starts at 5am every
morning
so when you have your alarm clock set
for 6 a.m
it's uh the first week it was a bit
annoying do you get used to it but by
the second lake ellen it just gets into
your soul
and became the most magnificent here's a
beautiful thing
if you don't know now you know he was
talking about the call to prayer
this is the adan he was hearing it and
he was just
in the beginning because he would set
his alarm clock for six
but then the and then the call to prayer
would go off at about four and this is
the first
muslims remember a muslim is one who
submits his or her
will because every person wants to have
peace contentment solace in life i mean
so when a person realizes what their
purpose in life is and they connect to
the one who created this world and tells
them what their purpose and they strive
they sincerely humbly try to live that
purpose
that per person is considered a muslim
one who only submits to god to the
creator that heavens and earth
so then he's seeing he's talking about
how uh
he would hear this as then the call to
prayer
and then at first it was just annoying
but then it just got into his heart it
got into his soul
so you guys most of you have seen this
and then i'll get to the part
soon which is the new part for me at
least
what was just said it says god is the
greatest allah god almighty allah just
simply means god the god the only one
worthy of worship so he would hear this
he would hear that and it's just saying
that god is the greatest god is the
greatest
there's nothing worthy of worship except
god except the creator that heavens in
the earth
so then we move on and this is the clip
now
that i wanted to get into where the
muslim call to prayer starts at like
five o'clock in the morning so it's an
extraordinary sound wow so the first
week it was like
the second week it was like oh it's kind
of quite nice but the third week i was
totally captivated by
loved it stan i thought maybe islam is
the answer
so i don't see any prayer rugs around so
i haven't
i don't think you've made the leap no
i've made the big leap yeah
i'm not sure what they think in ballet
meanwhile that wouldn't get done very
well
that would not they'd say oh muslim are
you a catholic muslim or a protestant
that's what that would be now that's
really what caught my attention loved it
captivated it's just the same story he's
repeating it but this time to anderson
cooper so i wanted to take this time now
to hopefully
that many of us can get on board and we
can go ahead and try to
revive what possibly liam neeson lost at
that time and many people
because anything worthwhile takes
effort it takes effort so at that time
liam neeson
he experienced something and then he
came back home
to share his experience and you saw he
was on different tv
the ellen show the anderson cooper
interview and others
and there was a talk about him
potentially accepting islam
we just finished in east dumbo we were
there for two months
but just before christmas beautiful city
unbelievable
place and the call to prayer happens
five times a day and for the first week
it drives you crazy and then
it just gets into your spirit it's the
most beautiful
beautiful thing and these mosques
there's
4 000 mosques in the city
some of them are just they're stunning
really makes me think about
becoming a muslim becoming a muslim
becoming a muslim that was the talk
of the town but you can imagine how much
heat
and how much pressure would be on
someone of that magnitude
accepting islam again just to qualify
what islam means again
islam simply means to acquire peace
everything you i
everyone wants in life peace and the
only way a person is going to have that
true peace and contentment in life
when everything is going wrong when
everything's upside down because there's
no perfect life there's no paradise in
this life paradise is for the next life
when a person is living purpose that's
when they get that peace
and that's what islam is it calls a
person to have peace with their creator
by submitting his or her will
to the one who created creation the one
and only creator of the heavens and
earth god almighty allah that's what
islam is so
liam neeson was considering that he was
considering accepting islam
he said maybe is islam the answer i was
totally captivated by
loved it stan i thought maybe islam is
the answer
really makes me think about becoming a
muslim but the question is
what if it is the answer and we know a
hundred percent without a doubt
islam is the answer submission to the
creation is not the answer but
submission
if we rephrase it to the creator is the
answer so we want to take this
opportunity invite liam neeson to
come back to that original state when he
was there when he was there in turkey he
was experienced that and compare
and same thing for everyone out there
someone who had some exposure to islam
or someone who was just looking
they look and and remember this look you
don't like
scream and fuss when someone's inviting
you to something bad when someone's
inviting you to go to the nightclub
to go to a pub to a bar you don't scream
at that person so
when somebody's inviting you when your
friend or your neighbor your colleague
when someone is inviting you to the most
beautiful
thing that you can do to have a
connection with the creator that heavens
and earth to live your true purpose in
life
you should feel a sense of of happiness
that this person is actually calling me
to something good something great
so all of us can be a part of that to
help get this to any individual out
there who's seeking
peace and purpose especially our friend
liam neeson who i'm sure
at that time was really considering
accepting islam so now you guys heard
the statement that whatever you focus on
it grows
and whatever you neglect it withers and
dies so now at that time
or at this time you right now you've
considered like okay i've experimented
everything
you're not even at that level of nissan
where you've been in all these films
you've got all this money and
all the the pleasures of this life open
up in front of you
but maybe you've had those things you'll
be dreaming about those things you might
not ever acquire those things
maybe you have i i don't know but you
there is one thing that you are
you're tired you're exhausted you really
want to know what's your purpose in life
why am i here everything around you has
a purpose
what about the human being so we invite
liam neeson to go back
to that state how he was feeling then
because time has passed and the person
is just getting closer to their dd
departure date
and it's really time to think like how
many more movies are gonna am i gonna
make how many more grammy events
am i gonna be invited to how many more
fake people are am i gonna be around
how many more night clubs am i gonna go
to how many times am i gonna go get
drunk and have hangovers and
how many men how many women i'm gonna be
with and how much money does it take to
make me happy at the end of the day
nothing will truly fill your heart
with peace contentment solace is
is it's it's only when you connect your
heart back to the crate of the heart
when you connect your heart back to the
cradle that happens on earth
and when you start living purpose and
i'm not talking about taking the means
because there are many means to the
ultimate purpose
uh to have a family that's one of the
means uh
to make a honest day's living is one of
the means
but i'm talking about to really live
life
according to how your creator wants you
to live and back to that statement
whatever you focus on grows
imagine now when you're given that
opportunity like right now or liam
neeson
at that time and a lot of times we have
that mentality that like winning team
mentality and
we have the truth it's always been
attacked islam is always being attacked
so now you feel like okay what are
people gonna say so time still goes on
and people forget
but you traded off you sold your soul
you sold yourself
more for what for fame for money for
popularity rather than that
that treasure was presented in front of
you
and how many people they lose that
treasure because they're more worried is
that group
think mentality what my friends
foes are going to say if i go down this
direction i'm not sure what they think
and belly me now that wouldn't get done
very well
that would not they'd say oh muslim are
you a catholic muslim or a protestant
so nobody's perfect practice makes
progress so take some time little baby
steps
start to leave off some of the vices
some of the things that you know are not
good for you
start forming a direct connection with
your creator by asking the creator
for guidance for guidance and start
surrounding yourself
by good people who will be a good
example around you cut off the bad
friends cut off the bad company
cut off the bad places that you know you
shouldn't be around
and start to clean up your life and
break the biggest
idol that can be you most of the time
your ego
and really humble yourself and then
start looking into islam
really look at islam look what islam is
all about look what islam calls you to
take a look at it just humbly sincerely
so get to know islam get to look into
islam so i just wanted to share this
with you because i thought it's very
very important
and the key message when the truth comes
to you take advantage of it it came to
him at that time
he was in a muslim country it really
touched his heart
and in the purpose of life is mentioned
that there's nothing worthy of worship
that's that first statement except the
creator of the heavens and earth allah
and muhammad is a slave servant
and final messenger so get to know what
the statement means get to know islam
from the correct sources
not from people who are perpetuating
hate and misinformation
and tune into the deen show so hopefully
you can grow
and learn the pure monotheism that the
creator calls the human being
through islam to have and that system of
living a morally upright life the
blueprint for life that's all there
in islam so liam neeson hopefully god
willing
some of the deanshill fans can get this
message to him and others who are really
searching to know what their purpose in
life is why they're here
and where they're going most importantly
when they leave this world because at
the end of this journey
there is a paradise and there is a
hellfire so what we live for
in this life what would determine where
we're going
in the next life so we ask god almighty
to guide
us all of us so we can live a beautiful
pure life
a life how god almighty wants us to live
in this life so we can get the wonderful
rewards
of gender paradise and the next and we
can avoid the hellfire thank you very
much
subscribe again to the dean's show hit
that notification bell like this video
help us get this out to our friend liam
neeson
and others and support us on our patreon
page we'll see you next time peace be
with you assalamu alaikum